quentin il a utilisé en chirurgie
esthétique pour devenir un personnage
public
alors vous êtes très fier de votre
ressemblance avec la poupée ken grâce à
ça j'ai une carrière internationale
vous allez nous raconter tout ça dans un
instant et vous allez me dire il paraît
que je suis un petit peu responsable
responsable donc totalement responsable
totalement est méritée ça me fait
plaisir
vous êtes sosie de ken officiel français
effectivement je le fais en section
sociale se dire quand vous allez par et
non pas la boulangerie vous êtes-vous
jour je suis ken américaine à la
boulangerie c'est vrai non mais c'est
pas leur temps oui j'avais qu'elle h 15
j'ai 25 ans 25 ans vous avez étudié donc
la chirurgie esthétique parce que vous
étiez fan de kent
alors j'ai toujours été fan de kent
effectivement puis du coup on s'est
croisé une fois et j'ai fait un
documentaire pour france 4 à l'époque
permis de conduire d'accord j'ai fait un
très beau score
et du coup j'avais une grosse voiture en
la voiture de kent cheveux au vent et du
coup vous avez relevé vous avez dit mais
ce mec ressemble à ken portrait voilà et
je me suis dit pourquoi pas cultiver ce
personnage et du coup bah il en aiguille
au jour et voyager
j'aurais dit au sommet qu'on dirait une
rico mathias laurier théorie comment ça
s'est passé ou alors on va voir leurs
ventes à huy abbaoui à voir combien de
temps ça c'était hier combien de temps
il ya quatre ans là quatre ans qu est-ce
que vous avez l'air vous avez très
heureux content je suis très heureux
très d'épanouir parce que du coup si
vous voulez j'ai voyagé j'ai fait plein
de choses je pense à ça grâce à ça parce
que du coup il faut savoir que dans le
monde entier
où est le riken on m'appelle quai louis
mais il y en existe partout donc j'avais
leucan au brésil le canada l'union kane
ont fait des réunions des shootings des
téléréalités et justement des
téléréalités dans des cliniques dans le
serré et qualaa oui dans l'année donc
vous retrouver tous tous les cas du
brésil quête du mexique juste ingenica
rodrigo alves que vous connaît tous ce
moment où on fait des gros tabloïd est
ce qu il faut savoir que en amérique 1
ça cartonne
même en russie c'est le week-end c'est
fou un sujet qui est débattu alors vous
voilà
et à chaque émission home offre ce genre
de poupée donc voilà alors j'ai rien ici
on est des bas on a rien à la salle on a
en a rien du tout alors je vous avait
récemment rompu avec votre copine
anastasia resco cela est le sosie de
barbie alors ça ça a été une feinte de
la production londonienne
on avait un peu court une feinte une
femme pourquoi non mais vous étiez
vraiment avec elle on peut là bas du
pont on n'aime pas tout non non non je
pas de procès on va éviter là encore pas
de procès mais un ami en mode mise en
demeure on va éviter si vous voulez ça a
été une fois requis une histoire qui a
été monté par the sun
parce que en fait l'histoire je le dis
aux téléspectateurs c'est que vous aviez
rompu avec elle parce qu'elle l'avait
fait une teinture brune c'est la presse
qui a pris ça c'est un engouement et ses
parties jusqu'en chine pour vous dire au
niveau presse voilà cinq ans que j'ai
une presse internationale à cause de
tout ça alors vous avez subi 50
opérations et injection s'avère en fait
quoi en fait faut faire pour devenir
kent ben j'ai fait le nez la bouche les
pommettes le front les oreilles ah ouais
fs vous avez même les fesses de kent et
oui un nom n'a pas été vérifiée lors et
c'est vrai ce domaine la personne va
faire attendre deux minutes
cela dit le fond les chirurgiens ont
accepté ce genre d'élève l'invention
alors alors vous regardez s'il veut
absolument il quentin franchement je
vous le dis et c'est plutôt réussi qu'en
tant il est beau et ça c'est réussi mais
mais ça pouvait être dangereux
oui ça pourrait être dangereux quand ils
disent quoi vos parents vos proches
mes parents non parce qu'ils sont très
tolérants et les heures merci à cette
heure-ci ce que mes parents sont
playmobil en fait sûrement avec du crack
reconnu mes parents sont tolérants et je
les fais en fait trop agressivement donc
ce n'a pas été un choc
voilà non mais riche en afrique elle a
raison je vous a réagi mais je
travaillais d'accord à payer tes
exactement et les prix des productions
aussi payer parce que quand je fais qui
m'en faisait des voyages
quand je partais en clinique ou en télé
réalité ah oui j'étais dans les hôpitaux
dont cheikh très bonne très bonne
remarque parce que de virginie mine de
rien toutes ces opérations toutes ces
injections ça vous a coûté combien à peu
près il faut quand même sortir un billet
de cinquante mille 50 millions à me away
ou un appart ou ressemble à ken quoi
bein il ya un entretien après c'est
comme une voiture
cui bas à bien
vous avez une voiture ni ferrari vrai
gain l'entretenir aller faire la vidange
par bordeaux vous mettre de l'essence
il faut le remplir un visage parfois
devenir bonne alors qu'est ce que les
mecs vous aviez craqué aussi la taxe non
mais quand un canton vraiment c'est bien
qu'on en parle parce que maintenant on
aborde un sujet quand même qui est qui
et quand même epinoux c'est vrai que toi
donc toi tu dois tu dois faire
soit tu dois faire quoique mais comme
toutes les personnes qui ont recours aux
chirurgies il faut savoir que ça
s'adresse à pezens et qu'on fait là et
ça dégonfle nom plein de personnes qui
n'ont plus d'argent après on les voit
ils sont ils sont fades sa tombe
bon bah mais les prothèses les
progressions des messages comme les
autres pourquoi ça tomberait vous avez
quel âge
moi g kg 25 ans le mandat du haut débit
pourrait coûter 25 ans alors il faut
savoir que la chirurgie esthétique le
botox ou là l'acide hyaluronique il faut
le faire plus tôt on en a des papes deux
ans il faut le faire écouter moi même
pas vingt dix pour le faire plus tôt
pourquoi est ce que justement l'arrivée
va creuser
c'est bien quand vous avez une tranchée
sur le visage ils vont à 25 ans il est
si cyril vance et de fantastique s'est
alors dit à quelqu'un qui nous disent
qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut savoir
alors qu'il ya un chirurgien plasticien
qui lui si j'en ai tellement fait lyon
dès que j'étais pas pour ou contre
j'étais plutôt mitigé parce
qu'évidemment ça dépend des cas mais là
cette chirurgie là je suis complètement
contre quoi parce que c'est une
philosophie une approche de la vie et
effectivement on a c'est une
marchandisation c'est à dire je m'achète
mon nez comme je m'achète ma voiture où
je m'achète rythme et est donc la
définissez de la base on est
effectivement dans une dérive et mes
docteurs si je puis me permettre si je
vous en prie challenge mais ce jeune
homme a manifestement en fait sa
profession de sage et bien d autres
choses il veut vendre après c'était
calme mais ça mais appelle l'attention
qu'elles doivent arrêter
oui c'est tout con fait aussi non enfin
la patte du tout le tour de nos mails à
toi tu es baudelot a donné trois fois
sous les marchés montrent la chirurgie
mammaire contre la chirurgie esthétique
je suis contre les dérives
la dérive la même série maintenant tu ne
mets quand vous dites que ce pape est
non alors être 3 justement on va voir on
va voir ce qu'en pense notre
éditorialiste et juste après on aura
quand même la ville notre chirurgie
esthétique est juste à côté
euh non lorsque vous êtes content vous
moi je suis de l'avis inverse du docteur
c'est à dire que dans le cas de quentin
c'est presque une démarche artistique on
appelle ça le bouddha garde c'est de
travailler sur son propre corps et d'en
faire une oeuvre d'art moi je mets ça de
côté sauf qu'il a évolué il va vieillir
non mais ça c'est son problème ça sera
qu'une fois là où je suis complètement
moi ces deux canadair alors je suis très
opposé à la chirurgie esthétique c'est
quand c'est la dictature de certains
critères de beauté à toutes les femmes
veulent à s'aligner sur un certains
critères il ya une pression ni social et
psychologique
là on n'est pas dans ce cas là non je
veux ressembler à ken je fais de mon
corps et ça a l'air devant là je mets ça
a failli oui en revanche s'approche sur
leur sg fait que c'est terrible de
pousser les femmes à passer sous le
bistouri parce qu'elles veulent
ressembler à telle ou telle vedette
alors il a même dépassé alors justement
vladimir mythe est avec nous vous êtes
auteur de chirurgie esthétique pour ou
contre vous avez un cabinet privé dans
le 6ème vous avez exercé à l'ap-hp dont
4 vous avez démocratiser la chirurgie
esthétique dans les hôpitaux
vous mettez en garde sur les ratés de la
chirurgie les dérives et éthiques
est ce que vous voyez quentin qui a
l'air très heureux et qui vit de ça
maintenant on sait votre métier ça a été
mon métier là je me suis calmé ça vous
fait quoi maintenant contrôleur des
impôts est pas du tout j'ai fait des
études de stewart
de quoi de stewart stewart à ça je
croyais ce qui bouge je croyais que
c'était stewart mais ils voient l'offre
que des yaourts
vous êtes six mois voilà j'espère
comprendre et ça risque rien pour
l'avion toussaint mais pas du tout quoi
sans rigoler parce que si on est assez
fort et les filles qu'on ait prothèse
qui ont plus de dix ans qui éclate
oui d'accord vous savoir rien à plus de
dix ans mais non